siamo ritornati ragazzi con un nuovo
video di come si sa è oggi due volte su
due vittorie su due impressioni e
parenti partiamo subito così da se ci
pensi è sempre la partenza dei nostri
video qui e poi pero pensiamo io la
chiamo la seconda partita la prima
abbiamo sempre vinto l'importante è
partire bene tanto la gara in pochi e
dato dobbiamo avere è giusto che poche e
facciamo anche sembra però cosa che
secondo gol che si palestra non sud e
vogliono sorren dare a me va bene non lo
possono fare perché aiuta l'altro sta
cosa non l'ho mai capita perché ero che
the league non puoi suren dare se non
passa un minuto perché è vero la sai
cosa guardano
eh sì se professore ha raggiunto papà ti
fa fare abbandona partita ragione è vero
vichingo non può sul rendere più minuto
qualcosa del genere l'onore della
partita che ne sono gli occhi gli si sa
di chi gli chiede una parola che mi sono
pagato ma ancora in mezzo a vita
no l'ho tolta ma se mi salta è finita
qua io l'ho messo in mezzo gigi mi
dissocio
no io dovrei fare io non mi sarei mai e
la messa i nostri al gol
aveva anche gli stiamo giocando la
nostra porta di guarna gara è stata io
nel dubbio
aspettami la metà dei gol bellissimo ove
dai abbiamo giocato gli abbiamo fatto
fare un buon noi perché se no è tutto
voluto uno turbo bravo tiro io conosca
vestivo turbo ma quello le prende tutte
cosa sai cosa lei giulia dove vado lui
no ma l'avevo vampate di me che la lega
chiude di michele galdieri mia carica
così gli mega carico io l'ho ben fatti
in porta per noi vi faccio tirare ci
complichiamo le partite da soli è vero
peccato perché ce lo stavo tenendo fermo
nient'altro vai vai sulla pratica ferma
chi contrario il contrario di fermat
quello poi rimbalzata così o dai visto
vabbè ma hanno fatto tre gol in trenta
secondi
ma che cosa posso dire da 2 a 0 a 2 a 3
va bene perché gol stupidi cioè nel
senso
andiamo ma ciao io questo file per
quest'estate colpiti della mia carriera
perché ho visto quello che la lisciata
ancora prima di lasciarla guarda lo ha
volato a casa sua e poi io già avevo
capito che non poteva farlo perché come
facente e quindi niente l'ho toccata
semplicemente molto l'inter grazie jaden
costello
non sto capendo la mancata attenzione
attenzione attenzione di pari valore a
casa questa uno è bruttina
no è orribile ma tra la mancata dal muro
la mancata dalle mura è colpa mia
un minuto e 22 per recuperare vi fate
trigger aree ecco se consegniamo questo
poteva staccare il video che fanno
venire più anzi a quelli proprio perché
il motivo sì sì sì è stato dove non puoi
sbagliare lo vuoi sbagliare in
automatico 44 55 secondi anche questa è
iper combattuta non ce la facciamo con
la partita normale no io te l'ho detto
per chiamare alla mia attenzione quello
parte sì
si faci di prova io la rispetto
ok allora ho fatto non ho turbo però ci
provo
me l'ha preso lui maledetto gira in
castello
ho tolto quel importarlo tolte importa è
che brutto vado di vincere ma va bene
esatto però devo fare tu te ne vai
seconda partita di oggi ragazzi con
carta vetro è pietro guarda le immagini
che bellini le vinciamo una con distacco
da nomi lamento è una bella proposta
possiamo anche provare a non soffrire
fino ai supplementari
allora questo va tentare di ripartire
forse non riesci a lo arrivo io che
controllo due volte sono in capo devo
fare ti giuro che volevo fare questo
lettere solimena ritocca io nel
ricontrollo la tiro ma parla e ha
funzionato perché quello non se
l'aspettava per una volta che faccio
qualcosa che funziona è le tanto
capitava temi vantare di questi gravi
cambia perché piette dall'avatar è molto
aggressivo allora ok ok ok ok
e allora vinciamo questa partita a casa
e alla che vogliono 3 a 0 tiene a latina
la porta si sono scaldati con ok va bene
avevo chiesto l'abbiamo benessere
avrebbero le riferì delle tre punti dai
33 33 tutti l'altro non sono tutti i sei
sono un casino manca ancora un gol e poi
l'ex teheran e la partita quindi non
facile la super e gol
non facciamoci fregare assolutamente per
la pelle turbo io tiro da qua ok hai
visto l'ho tirata talmente forte e
sorgenti vada bene tornata lire jabil e
ha fatto il giro del mondo ragazzi
bellissimo non è vero che glielo messa
vedi che a un certo punto meritiamo a
cercare di regalarglielo proprio proprio
di natale bellino positiva e lc gratis
poteva essere ancora meglio però va bene
mammamia lo stefan è lo stesso che dice
di no pure andare sia pf che costava tra
cosa vuoi fare
cosa vuoi vediamo niente no e devo
continuare
va bene anche il 5 facciamo il 5 ma
apparentemente non hanno neanche più
voglia di giocare
si vedono lami stata proprio 40 bella
allora al nobel bella non è un ruolo
però ci vado io che verrà parla ancora
in mezzo la puoi toccare pugnare per una
lisciata che lui il doppio liceo dai tre
minuti il doppio lino ecco 41 attenzione
dell'argento che sarkozy perché gliela
regalo più o meno dio cori capita
vogliamo fare il 5 devono perdere ogni
speranza la 55 si sarebbe utile madonna
che si perché sono toccati in un mondo
diverso allora io me la controllo sai
che ti dico
mamma mia come pressato st palla non lo
so veramente una scatoletta di tonno
ok bellissimo che aspettate dove
rimbalza lì allora dos che io sono la
mancino al posto loro
spero che livina veramente pristina che
si sia a questo punto si no vabbè che
gli usa iscrivesse può salire su youtube
è però non li sto lì rino non lasciate
attiva veniva pareggio con devono ancora
niente hanno segnato io
io ho segnato da solo gli eletti o
semplicemente la rai che sono scarsi e
che si sono abbandonati a loro la testa
ti prego da farla foto
cosa è successo quella quando su
telegram allora vado mi chiamo wright da
youtube
mambo grazie ci vediamo possiamo video
ragazzina ciò che mi piace un bel
commento si chiede anche di step e noi
ci vediamo come sempre hanno seguito da
ragazzi
[Musica]